m g vous
je peux à vous avez le temps le temps
est une illusion
seul compte l'instant présent
et présentement c'est bon tu doit
maintenant passer à la prochaine étape
du parcours
le guerrier doit devenir professeur je
suis prêt à lui lamentable
qui êtes vous je suis à la recherche de
mon fils
et qu'est ce qui nous prouve que vous
êtes son père et salah c'est toi qui
viens avec moi il y un village de bande
à cacher dans les montagnes
à
bienvenue à la baisse son système quand
c'est drôle on dirait mon portrait mais
en petit vous aussi mais en beaucoup
plus où il est adorable qui la pitoyable
d'appel dangereux le faiseur de veuves
bas n'est pas mais si je travaillais
avec gouaille attaqué la ville a tout
détruit
maintenant il va s'en prendre aux
pandores qu'il faut que tu leur
apprennent à se battre ça y est je suis
très je vais faire de vous des maîtres
du kung fu personne n'a dit que ce
serait facile
ils tous la justice
laquerre été caressée l'oubli alors
c'est toi le guerrier dragon c'est pas
vrai tu en viens aux fêtes jackass est
ce vraiment pareil de temps à être de
jackass et d'autres trucs astuces
jackass
je dois tu jackass qui jacassent
catholique est bon royal et l'armée
maître shifu a dit content tu as peur
même maître poulet il va et c'est une
poule mouillée